so if you've been keeping up with the
Justice League and with the DC EU you
know that there is some mythical
Schneider cut of the film out there it's
been pretty amusing to watch because the
Justice League wasn't very well received
from the fans so fans are demanding that
the Schneider cut be released when we
don't even really know if it exists
there have been rumors that it is true
there have been rumors that it's not
true you have people speaking up saying
that it's not true but at the same time
Snyder keeps liking all these posts on
Twitter so does it exist does it not
exist will we ever really know one thing
that is for sure is that if it does
exist or if it did exist it would be
much darker than the Justice League that
we received and now we've received a new
visual effects reel that shows a more
true version of the original storyboard
art that Zack Snyder had used and it
looks a lot more like his style
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
honestly watching this clip that is just
under a minute it almost looks like a
trailer and after watching this it makes
me feel like if Justice League hadn't
come out yet this looks like a fantastic
movie I really like this reel I like the
individual clips of each individual
member of the Justice League and I like
the visual effects that went along with
them I like this more because I do think
it's more true to the original art that
was done by Christian sure and it was
originally supposed to be more
apocalyptic Steppenwolf was supposed to
terrorize the earth more than he
actually did in the movie and the final
battle was supposed to be a lot darker
than it was and you can see in this
second clip which is very short these
triangles that are shown are actually
supposed to be parts of Earth that have
been destroyed by Steppenwolf so this is
kind of where it was at before Snyder
left it definitely gives you a glimpse
of what it could have been like if he
stayed and honestly it looks like it
probably would have been better but
these do bring up the question again is
there a Schneider Cut version of the
film we just received this reel that he
worked on and it has been rumored that
he is working on his own version outside
of a studio and again there's a lot of
stuff about the Snyder cut on social
media and Snyder gets on and likes all
of it
so maybe there's an actual version that
exists and one day he'll release it to
us so we can see it or maybe he's just
trolling everybody but what do you all
think do you think that this mythical
Snyder cut version of the Justice League
exists or not
and do you think if it does that we'll
ever get it let me know what you think
in the comments below and of course be
sure to like this video and subscribe to
my channel so you can stay up to date on
the DC EU the MCU and everything
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof